yeah there we go this purpose really
enjoy ya know I mean maybe the locals
have you ever heard of Yahoo Answers
went on there couple times for a couple
things I'm not gonna talk about what
we're gonna try to solve some of the
most ridiculous ones are you ready
they're ready I swallowed an ice cube
hole and I haven't pooped it out that
can be dangerous right I would say go
straight to the emergency room any
advice I know that it's a really
stressful time right now it's gonna be a
horrible 24 hours while it makes its way
through your system you're gonna feel it
but just wait 24 hours wait it out and
you'll poop it out and I'm excited fast
yeah it will prove out oh yeah the whole
ice cube absolute done what is the right
age to start teaching my dog about sex -
[ __ ] - why's that why - I don't know
they grow faster than humans so it seems
like their brain would be more mature
birth birth at birth so they start
humping themselves when are we talking
to dogs can spiders have fun of course
they can every creature on earth can
have fun obviously what do you think
they have fun doing sewing webs - my
brother the most fun they expect my
swing build it does but we just don't
know how do i unbaked cake
you can eat it I mean it's still kind of
big but it's more digest
the consistency of once you started
staring I don't know Drake needs to know
this man named Drake needs to know I
don't think it's good didn't he thinks
it's reversible that is it's not
reversible why do my balls smell like
ham did your dog bring like ham in the
bed in it like was like in your pants
sweating if you aren't circumcised you
get a thing called smegma okay here's an
anatomy lesson coming there's this this
like cheesy like substance that stinks
every now and then and you got to wash
your privates really well so maybe he's
got smegma yeah weakened down to his
boss why does Mario wear gloves does he
have ugly hands he's a plumber is a
plumber yeah because he's a plumber and
he wants to wear like that's a logical
and handyman he's a handyman can I tell
by the smell of my husband's gas if he
has been cheating I think that there
might be some way you can find what the
food that he's eaten who prepared the
food what you know that's a tough one
how do I test to see if my turtle is gay
I like that as a parent you're thinking
about your child's sexual orientation
and I hope that you're asking that
question because you want to be
supportive if your turtle does turn out
to be part of the LGBTQ community which
I'm so grateful to have your turtle I
just say raise him or her in an
inclusive environment does anyone else
think that shrek is hot probably do you
know sorry no no
don't find what about when he turns a
new human what do you have you know you
want to tell me where that is you have
to ask Yahoo okay Yahoo
[Music]